después del puré de tomate en una obra
de Van Gogh es puré de papas que recibió
este cuadro de monet este domingo dos
activistas arrojaron una sustancia
amarilla al cuadro en un museo de
postdam antes de pegarse a la pared
[Música]
la gente se muere de hambre de frío la
gente se muere estamos viviendo una
catástrofe climática y lo único que te
da miedo Es la sopa de tomate o el puré
de patatas en una tabla
una práctica sorprendente contra la obra
de monet que fue subastada por 81
millones de dólares hace falta puré de
patatas en un cuadro para que me
escuchen ese cuadro no valdrá nada si
tenemos que luchar por comida aunque no
dañaron la pintura ya que está protegida
por un cristal los dos activistas fueron
llevados a la cárcel según anunció el
colectivo Última Generación la
organización a la que representan pidió
al gobierno alemán que tome medidas
drásticas para proteger el clima y dejar
de usar combustibles fósiles Aunque
Comprendo lo urgente preocupación de los
activistas ante la catástrofe climática
me escandalizan los medios con los que
intentan dar peso a sus reivindicaciones
las organizaciones ecologistas están
multiplicando los actos de desobediencia
civil para llamar la atención sobre la
crisis climática este viernes un grupo
de activistas pegó sus manos a varios
coches deportivos expuestos en el salón
de la automóvil de París algo que ya
tuvo lugar en Alemania